So when Megan asked me what So all the
other guest speakers that we've had
before when they were um when they
volunteered to do the to to share on on
a Sunday, they were asked what they
wanted their bio to be to be introduced.
And so Megan asked me what I wanted my
bio to be. And I was like, I don't care.
You just you know me. Like do something.
But then a little while later, I was
like, no, no, no, no. She needs to make
up stuff. And so I tried to convince her
to make up things because I wanted a bio
like after serving in World War II and
winning two Nobel Peace Prizes,
Christian and inventing AI, Christian
decided to give back and become a
therapist. But uh she was very southern
on what she did. Thank you for being
sweet. So um I want to start with a
prayer uh before we get into our sermon.
So, uh, Jesus, we thank you so much for
this opportunity to
listen to you, to hear you, to be aware
and present,
to keep our hearts open, to hear what
you want to say, but also to ask you to
protect us in the sense of there's any
nonsense that comes out of my mouth,
protect us from that. Let the things
that you want us to hear um integrate
into our hearts. Um and the things that
are unnecessary, let them
be shoved to the side. And we pray that
whatever you want to teach us today that
we are open and willing and able to hear
from you in this moment. We thank you in
Jesus name. Amen.
So for the next two hours, we will be
going on a journey. Just just joking.
Not next two hours. Um, we will uh do a
fairly normal length sermon. Um, but
before we begin, I have a couple of
lovely assistants that are here who I
want to pass out some there's going to
be some writing utensils and note cards.
Um, because I am a therapist, we're
going to have a bit of a experiential
moment towards the end. Have it ready.
Luckily, we're in a church that has
himnels everywhere. So, you will have a
hard hard surface to write on. anyone at
home, we love that you are here and
please, please, please be uh grab some
sort of writing utensil, some sort of
sheet of paper. It doesn't really matter
how big it is, but we will have a moment
closer to the end. It's not right now,
just so you know. We're going to have a
little bit of stuff that we're going to
do. Um, but thank you so much for my
lovely assistance. Um my hope during
this talk uh is that I will help you
better understand a human tendency that
we have and how God might challenge us
to overcome that human tendency.
So um you change the next slide. Our
brains are hardwired for a better safe
than sorry approach. And the reason our
brains are hired for that are wired for
that is because essentially
back many many many many years ago all
of our threats were physical dangers
around us that we were constantly trying
to avoid. And the
people that were able to survive those
physical dangers were able to reproduce,
pass on their genes, carry on their
society. So we have that tendency. The
problem is if you look at the picture
that I share, uh well go back one. Um if
you look at this one, uh sorry, super
clear. You look rubble, explosions,
whatever. Uh maybe a tornado in the
background. I don't know. I used AI to
make this one. Um the safe uh it's
clear, it's nice, it's wonderful, it's
very easy. The problem is that that is
not as simple. You can move to the next
slide. Um so I want to use a simple
example. I refer to this as the poison
plant problem. So this is me. Uh my wife
took this picture of me. This is I think
was what I put on my website for my
private practice for a while. Um and
it's still there. Um, I decided to
appease our AI overlords and ask them if
they could turn me into a caveman. And
so this is what they did. Um, I don't
love it. I tried it like four or five
times. I couldn't find a perfect one,
but that's me. Uh, the picture is hard
to see. There's a little woolly mammoth
in the background. That sort of thing.
So, I am uh a caveman
and I am trying to survive and I'm
hunting and I'm gathering. I'm doing all
the things that I need to do to get what
I need. And uh I find a plant and that
plant looks super tasty and I eat it.
And if I don't die, which was a high
probability, um I get really sick and I
get seared into my brain that that plant
is dangerous. Uh I know the berries, I
know the way the leaves look, I know all
the things about it. And I am terrified.
And so I for myself am constantly like
you know eagleeyed on that threat. Also
I'm going to tell my community I'm going
to say guys we need to avoid this thing
because this thing is harmful for us.
And so
the problem is
that let's see
that if I use avoid the avoidance
strategy of avoiding that poison plant
that keeps me safe. It keeps my family
safe. It keeps the people around me
safe.
But the thing is that uh we don't really
encounter physical dangers on on the
normal, right? Like we do like you guys
drive, right? and people are awful. Um,
and you know, the last time I
encountered woolly mammoth was like two
years ago, so that hasn't been an issue
for a while, but we don't really
encounter physical dangers. And so,
because our brains are constantly aware
of the physical dangers, um, they're
trying to fill in the imaginal space
that we have of other dangers. And so,
all of these other dangers become
emotional dangers.
We have this overactive imagination that
surveys the land and says, um, could
this person hate me? Could this person
not like me? Is this if I do this thing,
is it going to result in me getting
fired? Is it going to result in somebody
yelling at me? Things like that. Um, so
a couple of examples might be something
like my mom sends me a text and she
says, "Hey Christian, when you have a
minute, can you call me? I have
something really important I want to
talk to you about. My overactive
imagination then fills in the blanks and
says, "Oh no, what is it? Is somebody
dying? Is she hurt? Is you know,
something else going on?" Um, or
something that has happened to me
multiple times is I will be at work and
actually I have a really I love my
current job but my previous company that
I worked for uh was really unstable and
my boss would call me in her office
constantly and every single time I got
called into the office in my imagination
this was the moment I am I am told that
I am a fraud I am a failure and I am
fired. So in my imagination I have been
fired approximately 500 times and in my
real life experience I have been fired
maybe once and I say I'm going to say I
want to go this is not a really
important aside but I'm just going to
say it. I was working for a company
Brooker's grocery company. I was working
like as a you know person who fills the
carts and stuff and I started over time.
I was lazy and I didn't really want to
work. So I requested less and less
hours. Eventually, they stopped
scheduling me and then about six months
later, they sent me a letter and said,
"Thank you for your service at
Brookers." So, I think that's a firing,
but it wasn't like an outright firing.
It wasn't like you're awful and we're
going to get rid of you.
So, let's define the problem. You can
move to the next slide. Um, so what the
way we learn that emotions specifically
are threatening is in three specific
ways. The first one is modeling.
Modeling is when we encounter a parent
or a respected adult and that parent or
respected adult teaches us that a
particular emotion is problematic. So a
couple examples might be uh did someone
in our family when they were sad did
they quietly push through their sadness
or did they run away and hide when they
got sad? Like did they go into the other
room? So, you learn sadness, not an
acceptable emotion. If I feel sad, I'm
not going to share this. Um, Megan and I
were recently at an event um where a
person was very sad and I understand
why. Um, but they would like kind of
cough a lot as a way of like keeping
themselves from like choking the whole
choking back the tears concept. And so
that ended up being what we learn. But
we also learn in a way reverse lessons.
So let's say my dad was very very
aggressive and I figured out that that
aggression meant my friends never wanted
to come over. My mom avoided my dad.
Things like that. I might also learn
that anger is dangerous. Not because he
demonstrated it and I learned to demon
to do it. It's because he demonstrated
it. I learned it was damaging. So then
anger becomes an emotion that I don't
like. It makes me feel uncomfortable. Um
that is an emotion I don't like. that is
an emotion that makes me feel
uncomfortable but it has nothing to do
with that example. Then we have lessons.
So that's the second one. Lessons are
very explicit statements that are told
to us. Things like big boys don't cry.
Things like nice girls aren't supposed
to be angry. Most of them are explicit,
but
sometimes they're a little more subtle,
like if someone
um let's see,
if someone if you start to cry and
someone comes over and gives you some
tissues. Now, in some ways, that could
be a very comforting response. But I
don't know if you guys have heard this.
In some support groups,
it is actually considered unacceptable
for you to hand someone tissues because
handing someone tissues is saying, "Your
tears make me feel uncomfortable. So,
I'm trying to get rid of your tears
because they make me feel bad and I
don't like that. So, please stop." So,
I've I've heard of places where they'll
have a big circle and they'll keep the
tissue box right in the center. And if
you are crying and you want a tissue,
you have to walk to the center of the
group, grab your tissue, dab your tears,
and feel like it's a little extreme, but
also I understand that the concept. Uh
my favorite one is uh that of a lesson
is one my dad said all the time, which
was uh don't cry or I'll give you
something to cry about. The problem is
this. You never learn what's acceptable
to cry about. And so you're like, "Okay,
well, what I'm crying about isn't fine,
but also
what is?" Um, I guess my dad cried at
Braveheart, so I guess I could cry at
Braveheart. That's probably fine, but or
whatever movie that he could cry at, but
anything else really wasn't like
acceptable for tears. And the last one
is experience.
We learned through direct feedback. If
we say something, if we're vulnerable
and we're chastised for it, then we say,
"I'm not going to do that."
Unfortunately, some of y'all have
probably suffered some trauma and that
has taught you things being
uncomfortable and unacceptable. Uh, one
example for me just being a little
vulnerable is when I was uh, many years
ago about 20 years ago, I was serving in
a missions organization and during that
time I started developing OCD. Um, it
was a really intense OCD. I I don't
remember at that exact season what it
was, but the process of like washing my
hands and taking a shower probably took
me two hours of my life every single day
because of how intense my symptoms were.
And I remember going to one person, I
have no idea what made me choose to be
vulnerable with them, but I was like,
"This is what's going on. This is how
I'm struggling. This is what's going on
in my And his response was in this very
evangelical
uh non-denominational charismatic circle
was, "Well, then you must be
demonpossessed Christian. That must be
the problem." I'm like, "Oh, so of
course that feeling that that response
that made me feel a little chastised and
of course I'm not going to be open about
it." And it took many years before I was
willing to actually pursue treatment,
help, assistance, be vulnerable to other
people because that was a pretty
significant response that I experienced.
So, some of us we're we're kind of
different when it comes to emotions. We
uh some of us are fine with certain
things. If I told I don't have the
finances for this, but I if I was to say
that right after this I have uh acquired
a van and the cost and I will pay the
cost for all of us to go skydiving.
There's probably a good chunk of y'all
that will be a good hell no. And there's
a few of y'all that would be maybe. Um I
think I think my wife would be a
definitely yes. Um I'm trying to work up
my courage to eventually be able to do
that with her. Um we're going ziplining.
We're going on a ziplining tour soon and
that's already kind of making my
heartbeat faster. Uh, so let's switch to
this one which is the slide with
emotions. And I really like this slide.
It's like one of my most funny, not
funny, fun therapy slides. Um, but just
because it kind of itches my nerdy
therapy heart. Uh, which is every
emotion and its corresponding belief.
Uh, so I'll give a couple of examples.
Anger. You feel angry when you when
somebody violates your rights. If
certain people are not allowed in your
phone and they access your phone, you
get angry. If you have a purse and
somebody or your bag and somebody gets
in your bag, you're angry. If you're
driving on the road and somebody cuts
you off, they are violating your right
to space, to your bubble, to your uh
your your order in line and you get
angry. When you're anxious, you're
viewing something as a future threat.
You're thinking that something coming up
is dangerous. If I have to have if that
text that my mom sent me, the reason I'm
feeling like I'm getting anxious about
it potentially in that scenario is
what's going to happen? I don't know.
And so I'm predicting this future
threat. So it's it's all connected. Um
and so like guilt, you violating
someone's rights. If I feel like I've
done something, um I've in the past, not
meaning to, accidentally shared a secret
one of my friends shared with me and I
felt so bad about it because I violated
their rights to privacy. It was
something they shared to me that was
supposed to be kept between us. And even
though it was accidental, it was still
some way that I violated their rights.
Okay, so let's go to the next slide. And
this is basically just a summary of
what we've done so far. So we are
designed for preservation. We want to
survive. We have we have a lot of room
in our brains now because we don't have
physical danger that we're encountering.
And that has taught us to focus on our
emotions and that certain emotions are
dangerous.
And then we haven't gotten there yet,
but we develop strategies to avoid. So
what are those strategies? Let's move to
the next slide. And these are our
strategies. If you look at them, they're
not innately bad. Watching TV or movies,
perfectly fine.
Scrolling on social media, fine. Even
sleeping a lot. I I think I slept I
think I actually got like 11 hours last
night. I think that and I don't do that
normally, but it was awesome. So, all of
these things are fine. Um, but it's the
reason it's it's why we're doing it. If
we're doing it because something is
making us feel uncomfortable. If I get
in a fight with my wife and I'm like,
"That makes me feel really
uncomfortable. I don't want to have a
confrontation. I'm going to go into the
other room and I'm going to just spend
time by myself and watch Netflix. Like,
that's an avoidance strategy. That
doesn't help us. That doesn't help me.
That doesn't make the things better. Um,
I probably default to when I'm sad. I
kind of want carbs. Carbs are awesome.
So, cupcakes, tortillas, they're
awesome. Um, and I probably default to
Netflix or podcasts. Those are probably
my uh my strategies. But it really is
all about the reason why you do the
thing as opposed to the thing in and of
itself. Because
shopping,
exercising,
playing video games, not necessarily
wrong, but also the purpose that behind
why you do that those things.
Okay. So, let's move on to our next
slide where we're going to talk about
and I know this is probably very hard to
read, so I'm going to go through it real
quick. Um so if you look at it the top
thing is this is the cycle of avoidance.
This is how what we do when we feel an
emotion that we feel that we think is
uncomfortable to us. So you have to face
a difficult emotion. Somebody triggers
you have to encounter it. Instead what
you do is you avoid the emotion. And you
know what avoidance does? It feels
really good. You feel an experience of
relief and you are not you were like I
escaped from that danger. I feel really
really good. But the problem is that the
more you do it, the more you teach
yourself that that original emotion was
dangerous. You strengthen its intensity.
You make it more likely the next time
around that it's going to happen. And so
when people in your life do something to
anger you, then you stuff it down. You
go in you go in a different direction.
You grow more bitter. You stuff it down.
You go in a different direction. You
grow more bitter. you still feel like
you can't go into the actually dealing
with that anger and so it becomes worse
and worse and worse over time and it's
our tendency to do that and I know that
this is a lot of like psychology stuff
um but I do have a point and I am going
to actually reference I'm actually going
to go to the Bible like we will get to
the Bible um but I think that um I think
it's important to understand what our
tendency is with emotions and with
danger before we can understand how God
might want us to do something a little
differently. So, we're going to touch on
a little bit of Greek before we get into
the actual
uh passage that we're going to be doing.
So, on the next slide, we're going to
talk about the word truth. So this is
probably the reason when you think of
the word truth, you probably think of
something like this. Truth is fact,
truth is reality, truth is correctness.
U for if you're a Christian, this isn't
like me Christian version. This is like
the Christian community's version. Um
God's understanding of the world like we
we are able the truth is we see the
world like God sees the world. Um, and
some even people people it might even be
like the truth is actually like the
scriptures themselves, the word of God
that's printed to us.
But the word truth actually it's um it's
this Greek word called altheia.
So ah is without
un or not.
So a couple of examples might be
asymmetrical. So something is not
symmetrical. Asymptomatic, you don't
have any symptoms. Uh, apolitical,
you're not political. Amoral, you have
no morality. I know this is kind of me
repeating a lot of the same stuff, but
that's basically it. It's an unnot
uh without option.
Letha, Letha means hidden,
forgotten,
or concealed.
So if you put both of those two things
together,
the concept comes to
unavoidance,
unconcealment,
and unhiddenness.
So, if we were to go to this passage of
scripture that every one of you is
familiar with, I did choose a
translation that's not the normal one
just because I really liked how how it
worded it and it wasn't too far away
from kind of NIV.
Then you will experience for yourselves
the truth and the truth will free you.
Most of us would say then God will drop
a truth bomb on you and you will be
changed and it's this like massive huge
amazing thing that happens to us.
But it's kind of more and less
complicated than that
because if we alternate this a little
bit with the idea of unhiddenness,
then you will experience for yourself
unhiddenness
and that unhiddenness will set you free.
You will experience for you can you can
replace it with a few other options. You
will experience for yourselves
vulnerability. You will experience for
yourself the act of not living in
avoidance.
And when you choose to do that, when you
don't consistently, constantly avoid and
allow yourself to engage in the things
that make you scared, then that act is
the act in which God uses to free us. So
it's simple in the fact that it's not
necess it's more of a a relational act.
It's not just a like I'm going to pray
and be like God please bring about this
truth bomb that I need and it's going to
change me. It's an active activity. It's
something that we can engage in
experientially and relationally with God
to allow for change to happen.
So our tendency to avoid the way that we
are
the tendency to avoid the way that we
are hides us from that reality from
others and from our emotions.
In this verse, we're basically being
told that we need to not follow our
biological emotional instinct,
but instead we need to encounter,
engage, and be curious with our
emotions.
and to avoid the tendency
to
avoid the tendency to avoid. Uh this
choice can be very hard because we're
purposely putting ourselves in danger.
Not real danger, emotional danger
because we've decided that things are
emotionally dangerous. Um the first step
though is being vulnerable with
ourselves.
We don't just hide things from others,
but we first start by hiding things from
ourselves. Only when we engage in that
first level of I am
vulnerable to me can I then go to a
trusted other person and express that
vulnerability. Can I engage with my
community and feel like I can I can be
vulnerable and open with the community.
Um, one thing I do in therapy with
people is when I have my group, I will
have them do a journal activity and I
will very clearly say almost 95% of the
the handouts that I give to them, I say,
I would love for you to share, but it is
more important to me that you feel like
you can be vulnerable with yourself. And
if you if you feel like having an
audience of people that are going to
listen and hear your story, if that's
going to make you feel like you can't be
vulnerable, then don't do it. Like do
the activity. Just don't share it with
people. And that will allow you that
opportunity. So, we're going to do an a
a form of
engaging. So, I want you to grab your
card. Um I I I just want to be clear
about this. You're not going to share
with anybody. This is your own thing.
You're writing this all down for
yourself. So don't feel like any
pressure in that. But I am going to have
us uh do three things. I want you to
grab your note card, grab your pen, grab
a hard surface in front of you like a
himnil.
And then we are going to take a few
minutes. We're going to do this quietly
and I want you to answer these three
questions. Before I have you answer
though, if you can do me one favor, if
you can just pause for a minute and
close your eyes.
And before you breathe, what I want you
to do is I want you to take one deep
breath in through your nose and out
through your mouth. But I want you to
purse your lips when you blow out that
air and just stretch it as long as you
can.
And then after you do your breath and
when you feel comfortable, I'd like you
to take a few minutes and I'd like you
to answer these three questions.
Is there an emotion you found yourself
pushing away or trying to ignore
recently?
If that hidden feeling had a voice, what
message might it be trying to deliver?
And what small step could you take this
week to acknowledge that feeling's
presence?
Okay.
So, one suggestion if you so choose um
is to
take a picture of these questions and if
you want to when you have a moment and
are thinking about it at the end of the
day or
early in the morning just trying to be
vulnerable with yourself by asking
yourself that clarity by choosing to
take um I know Brett's really big into
this, but choosing to take moments of
silence where we
don't just always have something
constantly running in the background. I
know for me that's one of my biggest
things and it's not an avoidance thing.
It's an entertainment thing for me. But
when I'm in my car, I can't be in my car
in silence most of the time. But I
actively try to do that to shut off and
just leave music off for five or 10
minutes or a podcast and just give
myself that moment to be present to be
available.
So as we conclude, this isn't just an
exercise in self-help.
This is a divine invitation.
When Jesus said, "Then you will
experience for yourselves the truth and
the truth will free you," he wasn't just
talking about intellectual
understanding.
He was inviting us into unavoidance.
He was calling us to stop hiding even
from ourselves.
He was saying, "Step into the
discomfort.
Lean into the feeling. Lean into what
feels threatening." And there in that
vulnerability, you will find true
freedom.
This freedom isn't the absence of
difficult emotions. It's the freedom to
engage with them, to learn from them,
and to move through them
rather than being ruled by them.
It's the freedom that comes from living
authentically, open to all of who you
are because you trust that God meets you
in every single part.
This week, I encourage you to practice
unavoidance.
When that familiar discomfort arises,
instead of immediately reaching for your
usual avoidance strategy, be it Netflix,
busyiness, self-criticism,
pause, get curious.
What is actually there?
What is God inviting you to unhide
within yourself?
Because in that unhiddenness,
in that brave act of vulnerability,
you truly begin to live free just as God
intends.
So, now we're going to transition to
communion.